nouvelle rentrée des classes masqué pour
de nombreux élèves du primaire et
vacances de la toussaint terminé le
masque redevient obligatoire à l'école
dans 40 départements dans les
départements où le taux d'incidence est
malheureusement
restabiliser au dessus de 50 pour cent
mille habitants le protocole scolaire va
repasser du niveau 1 au niveau 2 c'est à
dire que le masque va à nouveau être
rendu obligatoire pour les enfants des
écoles concernées ces quarante
départements viennent s'ajouter aux 21
territoire où le port du masque à
l'école n'avait pas été levé autre signe
d'une reprise épidémique
le nombre de personnes actuellement
hospitalisé en soins critiques augmente
sensiblement plus 55 patients en une
semaine vendredi dernier jean castex a
appelé les français à la vigilance on
n'est pas sorti de l'épidémie ni en
france ni ailleurs l'heure n'est pas
venue de baisser la garde même si ce
n'est pas une explosion 80 départements
connaissent une reprise légère mais
réelle c'est dans ce contexte qu
emmanuel macron prendra la parole mardi
soir une allocution pour donner le ton
de la saison hivernale reconfirme ans et
couvre feu ne sont pas à l'ordre du jour
la france étant plutôt épargné pour le
moment par rapport à d'autres pays
européens
le président de la république devrait
tenter de persuader les non-vaccinés de
passer à l'acte par de nouvelles mesures
avec près de 75 % de français ayant
terminé leur schéma vaccinal le pays
possède l'un des taux de vaccinations
les plus élevés au monde mais la
troisième injection peine toujours à
convaincre au 2 novembre seulement moins
de 20 % des plus de 65 ans avait reçu
une dose de rappel